GOOD NIGHT, EVERYONE, HAVE A
GREAT
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
A HISTORIC MOMENT TODAY.
AFTER MUCH TRIAL AND ERROR AND A
GREAT DEAL OF ANXIETY AND
FRUSTRATED HER ROMPING ON CABLE
NEWS PANELS, THE DEMOCRATIC
ESTABLISHMENT FINALLY HAS BEEN
ABLE TO FIND A CANDIDATE’S TOP
BERNIE SANDERS BEFORE HE
CAN TAKE THEIR MONEY.
THE SANDERS THREAT IS IMMINENT
AND PROFOUND.
IMAGINAL GENERAL CHINESE GORDON
YOU’LL KNOW HOW THEY FEEL.
TERRIFIED.
IT’S ONE THING IF YOUR COUNTRY
FALLS APART, IF TENTH GRADERS
CAN’T READ A 9-YEAR-OLD ARE
TAKING PUBERTY BLOCKING DRUGS
AND DOWNTOWN L.A. LOOKS LIKE
CALCUTTA.
AMERICANS ARE DYING.
DEMOCRATS ARE FINE WITH THAT.
THEY CAN LIVE WITH IT.
THEY DO.
THEY DON’T SAY A WORD.
BUT IF THERE IS A REAL CANDIDATE
FROM OUT THERE WHO MIGHT BE
SERIOUS ABOUT CLOSING THE LOOP
HOLES IN FORCING PRIVATE EQUITY
BARONS TO PAY THE SAME TAX RATE
YOU DO, THAT CANNOT STAND.
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE.
MORALLY WRONG.
ALERT THE PANEL.
WE ARE GOING TO WAR.
TONIGHT THEY HAVE SIGNED THEIR
WARHORSE, HERE THEY IMAGINE WILL
CARRY THEM FOR THE VICTORY
AGAINST THE WILD HAIRED INFIDEL
FROM VERMONT.
THIS CANDIDATE IS THE YOUNGEST
MAN IN THE DEMOCRATIC RACE, THE
MAN THEY BELIEVE HAS THE
CONFIDENCE, INTENSITY, INTELLECT
TO REPEL THE SEETHING HORDE OF
SANDERS-ITES.
>> TOMORROW SUPERSTAR TUESDAY.
I WANT TO THANK YOU.
I AM RUSHING AHEAD.
150 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
KILLED SINCE 2007 WHEN BERNIE
VOTED TO EXEMPT THE GUN
MANUFACTURERS FROM LIABILITY.
IT WOULD PUT 720 MILLION BACK --
MILLION WOMEN BACK IN THE
WORKFORCE.
NOBODY SHOULD BE IN JAIL FOR A
NONVIOLENT CRIME.
MY NAME IS JOE BIDEN AND I’M A
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE FOR THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
PLAY THE RADIO.
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THE RECORD
PLAYER ON AT NIGHT.
FOURPOOR KIDS ARE JUST AS BRIGHT
TALENTED AS WHITE KIDS.
WE CHOOSE TRUTH OVER FACTS.
WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE
SELF-EVIDENT.
ALL MEN AND WOMEN CREATED BY --
YOU KNOW THE THING.
>> Tucker: THAT IS THE MAN.
IT IS SUPER THURSDAY.
RUNNING FOR THE UNITED STATES
SENATE IN MEMORY OF NEARLY HALF
THE COUNTRY MURDERED BY GUNS IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS.
GUIDED BY THE BELIEF THAT OTHER
CHILDREN AS BRIGHT AND TALENTED
AS WHITE KIDS NOT TO MENTION
CLEAN AND ARTICULATE.
HOPE THAT HE CAN PUT THREE
QUARTERS OF A BILLION WOMEN BACK
TO WORK WITH THEY WANT TO GO OR
NOT.
THAT’S THE KIND OF
TRANSFORMATIONAL CANDIDATE
YOU’RE LOOKING FOR, JOE BIDEN IS
YOUR MAN.
OR IF YOU’RE LOOKING FOR SOMEONE
TO GET YOU A SECOND SERVING OF
JELL-O, BIDEN CAN DO THAT.
HE’S A RENAISSANCE MAN.
HE WOULD TELL YOU THE
RENAISSANCE WAS AN AWFUL LONG
TIME AGO, BACK DURING THE CARTER
ADMINISTRATION.
JIMMY WAS A GOOD GUY, BETTER
THAN THEY SAID.
HOW DO YOU SAY THIS WITHOUT
BEING RUDE OR MEAN?
THIS WHOLE THING IS SAD.
WORSE, IT’S CRUEL.
RUNNING JOE BIDEN FOR
PRESIDENT IS LIKE MAKING YOUR
DOG WEAR A DRESS.
IT MAY MAKE FOR AN AMUSING
INSTRUMENT POST BUT IT’S WRONG.
YOU CAN SEE THE CONFUSION AND
THE DOG’S EYES.
YOU CAN SEE THE SAME THING AND
JOE BIDEN’S EYES IF YOU LOOK
CLOSELY.
WHY AM I HERE?
WHAT AM I TALKING ABOUT?
BE IF I MAKE A LOUD NOISE ABOUT
PUSH-UPS NO ONE WILL NOTICE.
SO FAR THE ONLY THING WE’VE
LEARNED IS THERE’S NO ONE AROUND
HIM TO MAKE THEM STOP.
THERE ARE ONLY ENABLERS.
TODAY PETE BUTTIGIEG AND
AMY KLOBUCHAR ENDORSED BIDEN,
SORTED HARRY REID AND
BETO O’ROURKE.
PARTY PEOPLE DOING THE BIDDING
OF THEIR CORPORATE MASTERS.
THEY ARE PUSHING A DEFECTIVE
PRODUCT ON CONSUMERS AND THEY
KNOW IT.
THEY ARE SELLING LONG DARTS --
LAWN DARTS.
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN ISN’T ABOUT
IDEAS OR IDEALS.
THE DEMOCRATIC ESTABLISHMENT
ONLY CONCERN IS INSTITUTIONAL
CONTROL.
THAT’S WHERE ALL THEIR POWER
COMES FROM.
FROM HOLDING TOGETHER AND
RUNNING THINGS.
IF THE DEMOCRATIC COALITION
BREAKS DOWN, THEY ARE BUYING --
BY DEFINITION POWERLESS.
THE REAL THREAT IS THE THREAT HE
POSES TO THE PARTY.
JOE BIDEN IS THEIR LAST CHANCE.
THAT’S WHERE THEY ARE BACKING
HIM.
THE ONLY GROUP SINCERELY
CHEERING BIDEN ARE THE
CREDIT CARD COMPANIES.
BIDEN WAS THEIR PAID LACKEY IN
WASHINGTON AND THEY BRIBED HIM.
THEY GAVE JOBS TO HIS SON.
IN RETURN HE CARRIED THEIR
LEGISLATION THROUGH CONGRESS
DUTIFULLY FOR MANY, MANY YEARS.
UNTOLD AMERICANS, AVERAGE SHOWS,
AS JOE HIMSELF LIKES TO SAY WERE
CRUSHED BY CREDIT CARD DEBT.
THE AVERAGE CARD INTEREST RATE
IS 21%.
21% INTEREST IN A TIME WHEN THE
FED IS GIVING BANKS BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS NEARLY FOR FREE.
THAT’S HOW LOW INTEREST RATES
ARE FOR THEM BUT YOU ARE PAYING
21%.
THIS IS A DISASTER.
HOW BAD IS IT?
ASK YOURSELF, HOW MANY PEOPLE DO
YOU KNOW PERSONALLY WHO HAD BEEN
HOSPITALIZED FOR CORONAVIRUS,
SOMETHING WE ARE WORRIED ABOUT
AND JUSTLY.
MAYBE NONE.
ASK YOURSELF HOW MANY PEOPLE YOU
KNOW PERSONALLY WHO’S LOTS OF
BEEN DIMINISHED OR DESTROYED BY
CREDIT CARD DEBT?
YEAH.
MAYBE IT’S HAPPENED TO YOU.
PROBABLY HAS.
IT’S HAPPENED TO SO MANY PEOPLE.
JOE BIDEN IS ONE OF THE
DECISION-MAKERS WHO MADE THAT
POSSIBLE.
IT’S NOT AN OVERSTATEMENT BUT
THEY DON’T CARE.
THEY ARE TELLING OF THE GOOD OF
THE COUNTRY YOU’VE GOT TO VOTE
FOR JOE BIDEN.
KEEP IN MIND THEY DON’T EVEN
BELIEVE IT AS THEY SAY IT.